[Musique]
depuis mardi dernier les collégiens haut
rhinois ont repris le chemin de l'école
au collège schickelé à saint-louis 90
élèves étaient attendus par 27
professeurs ce mardi 2 juin au collège
la reprise des cours et le retour des
ados étaient attendus après deux mois
d'enseignement à distance l'équipe avait
hâte que la coup et laissa une classe
reprenne vie c'est un moment d'émotion
parce que ça fait maintenant plus de
deux mois que ces collèges que ces
salles de classe étaient vides et que le
fait de retrouver ce matin et cet après
midi des enfants dans les collèges eh
bien on se dit voilà on reprend tout
doucement une vie normale même si on a
les masques même s'il faut respecter la
distanciation
on voyait que beaucoup de ces enfants
étaient très heureux de revenir au
collège et de retrouver leurs camarades
et aussi il faut le dire de retrouver
les enseignants que pour la plupart ils
n'avaient pas perdu de vue mais c'était
par visio mais c'est quand même autre
chose que d'être lent présentiel
une rentrée qui a bien sûr nécessité la
mise en place d'un important protocole
sanitaire sens de circulation
désinfection des mains
prise de température sont au programme
pour le seul collège schickelé le
document expliquant les procédures fait
33 pages guidés par les professeurs et
les marquages les élèves ont pu
commencer à se familiariser avec ces
nouvelles pratiques
c'est assez simple id rentrer au collège
ils observent les règles de
distanciation
ils savent parfaitement les règles de
circulation
ils savent parfaitement où se trouve le
gel comment ça se doit se passer
lorsqu'ils vont dans les sanitaires et
il avait déjà été le 2 mars puisque nous
avions très anticipée alors qu'aucun
établissement était fermée à l'époque
nous avions anticipé il savait déjà
qu'on me devait des corps entrer en
classe prend du gel hydroalcoolique ir
sortait pareil
il revenait gel hydroalcoolique on leur
avait appris très rapidement les gestes
barrière donc pour eux c'est un
changement mais c'est juste une
évolution par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
vécu avant le confinement pour l'instant
le retour des collégiens se fait sur la
base du volontariat
si le 2 juin plus de la moitié des
parents n'avaient pas souhaité envoyer
leurs enfants en cours
ils pourraient être plus nombreux dans
les prochaines semaines l'accueil est
cependant limitée à 50 % de l'effectif
en même temps ce qui pourrait à terme
poser des problèmes d'embouteillage pour
l'instant en capacité nous avons entre
25 et 30 % d'élèves qui pour l'instant
sont revenus nous pouvons à peu près si
on suit et on suivra le protocole
sanitaire monte à 50%
maintenant on pourrait monter à 100%
mais dans ce cas là ça ne serait pas une
scolarité à plein temps toute la semaine
nous serions obligés de faire des
groupes par demi journée et on pourrait
et scolariser les 441
dans les collèges haut rhinois on
souhaite que les premiers élèves à avoir
fait leur rentrée à y convaincre leurs
camarades de faire de même à saint louis
l'équipe préférerais de loin s'adapter
pour accueillir un maximum de jeunes
plutôt que d'en voir la moitié rester
loin des salles de classe au niveau du
ministère on plaide pour que tous les
élèves retrouvent le chemin de l'école
au moins une fois
d'ici juin c'est l'objectif qu'on
poursuit c'est de permettre à chacun de
nos élèves quel que soit le niveau de
scolarisation de revenir à l'école si
possible plus qu'une journée bien sûr
mais je crois que ça dépendra aussi du
nombre dans chaque collège où dans
chaque école dans chaque lycée du nombre
d'enfants à accueillir donc il faut que
les équipes trouvent aussi des
organisations qui permettent d'étend de
ce que de scolarité qui soient le plus
important possible mais aussi de ne
laisser sur le bord du chemin aucun
élève avant cette cette fin d'année
scolaire
et c'est sans doute là où justement le
travail qui consiste à rassurer les
parents a toute son importance pour
vraiment permettre à tous les enfants
quel que soit leur niveau de
scolarisation de revenir à l'école
pendant ces quelques semaines qui
précèdent les congés d'été
du côté des familles la réouverture des
salles de classe semble être bien
accueilli plusieurs semaines de
déconfinement dans les écoles primaires
auront peut-être aidé à lever certaines
appréhensions chez les parents des plus
grands ils ont envie que les élèves
reviennent bas pour plein de raisons -
des raisons qu'on peut très bien
comprendre c'est que en dehors d'eux
de tirer du lieu de culture quel collège
mais c'est aussi un lieu de
sociabilisation donc pour eux c'est
important que leurs enfants reprennent
le chemin de l'école c'est un galop
d'essai aussi pour eux pour voir comment
leurs enfants vont réagir ce qui
prédomine je pense que c'est la
confiance
il y a deux là beaucoup de communication
et surtout il ya un gros travail d
équipe d agents pour que cet
établissement soit le plus sécuritaire
possible
mardi 2 juin seuls deux collèges haut
rhinois n'avez pas encore réservé leurs
portes aux élèves les agents du conseil
départemental se sont mobilisés aux
côtés des professeurs pour rendre cette
rentrée possible dans les meilleures
conditions de sécurité
l'objectif en toile de fond préparer la
rentrée de septembre
ça va nous permettre pour la rentrée
d'affiner les choses de mettre en place
les aménagements nécessaires s'il le
faut nous avons la chance d'avoir à la
fois au conseil départemental mais aussi
au sein de l'éducation nationale dans le
haut rhin en alsace des équipes très
pragmatique et donc voilà nous ferons ce
qu'il faut pour que la rentrée du mois
de septembre se passe bien tout comme
nous avons fait tout ce qu'il faut et je
crois que c'est plutôt réussi
pour que cette reprise le 2 juin soit
une réussite dans l'urne